charlène fleury bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin dans la matinale de
rtl france alors vous êtes en ce moment
à glasgow et on l'a vu avec votre
collectif vous avez mené une action pour
dénoncer le double discours d' emmanuel
macron juste avant sa prise de parole
hier vous dénoncez quoi très précisément
parce que finalement le président
français à l'international il est
entendu sur ces questions du climat
alors ce qu'on dénonce en fait c'est le
double discours entre les actes et les
paroles des manuels macro parce que
manuel macro est certes entendu il se
présente comme le champion de la terre
il fait beaucoup de grands discours il
dit qu'il faut mais comme planète great
eagle mais à côté il a toute une série
d'actes en fait qu'ils ne sont pas en
accord avec avec ses paroles la france
n'est toujours pas sur une trajectoire
compatible avec l'accord de paris et le
président de la république encore d'un
certain soutien fort à des projets
climaticides c'est le cas de
l'implantation total en angola en
ouganda le fait que que le président est
aussi un soutien de de l'orientation
d'amazon en france il a signé un certain
nombre de traités de libre échange alors
que c'est justement ce qu'il a dénoncé
dans son discours hier en disant trop
d'entre nous prenne des engagements mais
s'il des traités de libre échange et pas
pourquoi dit il ça alors que lui même il
est dans cette case donc c'est très
problématique en fait ce discours-là
d'emmanuel macron parce que ça endort
tout le monde ça fait croire que la
france est vertueuse et sur une bonne
trajectoire or ce n'est pas du tout le
cas et donc ça on doive en fait toute
action et toute action structurelle pour
le climat en france et en europe et à
l'international en fait alors en tout
cas boris johnson hier s'est exprimée
est pour lui un échec de cette coop 26
déclencherait une colère et une
impatience incontrôlable il y a 6 ans
lors de la cop 21 à paris on parlait
déjà de la réunion de la dernière chance
néanmoins est ce qu'il ya eu des
avancées depuis
la coop 21 à paris et en est un jalon
fondamental dans le dans la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique puisqu'elle a
permis d'arriver à un acte or maintenant
le problème de cet accord c'est qu'il
n'est pas contraignant donc les états ne
le respecte pas et en particulier les
pays riches et les pays les plus
polluants qui ont une dette climatique
envers les pays du sud maintenant nous
ce qu'on attend la société civile ce
qu'elle attend c'est que les états
tienne ses engagements qui ont été pris
lors de l'accord de paris et qu'ils
aillent plus loin mais déjà si seulement
il les tenait ce serait déjà bien parce
qu'en fait on est on est sûr on est sur
un gars qui est trop important pour
l'instant ce que dit l'accord de paris
c'est qu'on a essayé de rester sous les
1 gélule 5 degrés or les engagements
cumulés de tous les états nous font
arriver vers un monde à 2,7 degrés en
2100 donc en fait on n'est pas du tout
sur des engagements qui sont en accord
avec ce que l'accord de paris dit est
déjà là les rangs problème donc si on
pouvait revenir à cette ambition
première emmanuel macron dans son
discours hier a beaucoup dit ambitions
transparence confiance et cetera mais
tous ces mots là son creux et vide si on
ne revient pas à l'accord initial et si
on ne dit pas qu'on va vraiment le tenir
et qu'on va vraiment et bien obtenir les
engagements qui ont été pris et qui sont
déjà insuffisantes par ailleurs puisque
à 1,5 degré ça n'est pas un monde qui
est souhaitable en fait donc pour vous
il faudrait les des accords
contraignants finalement des sanctions
contre les pays qui ne respectent pas
les accords sur le climat
oui ce serait l'idéal le problème c'est
que c'est quasiment impossible d'arriver
à un tel résultat donc de négociations
internationales aussi complexe donc nous
ce qu'on aime à dire c'est que la
société civile est la contrainte qui
manquent à l'accord de paris nous sommes
en mettant la pression et toutes et tous
les citoyens la contrainte qui manquent
et donc c'est un peu ce qu'il a dit ce
qu'il a dit le président britannique
part dans le
britannique hier c'est que en fait on va
arriver à des à des manifestations des
mobilisations et peut-être des crises
sociales très importantes si on n'est
pas à la hauteur aujourd'hui à 70 6 en
tout cas plusieurs actions
son vont être discutés les dirigeants
mondiaux doivent notamment s'engager
aujourd'hui à interrompre la
déforestation d'ici la fin de la
décennie le brésil qui doit signer aussi
cette déclaration un bon cap selon vous
oui c'est un bon début toute action et
tout ce qui pourra être être mis dans
cette dans cet accord enfin si on arrive
à un accord lors de la cop 26 était un
bon début maintenant le problème en fait
nous semons dénonce c'est que on est
devant des personnes qui sont des
pompiers pyromanes qui disent quelque
chose qui font que l inverse de l'autre
côté et donc même si on a des accords on
les croit plus on a l'impression que
emmanuel macron va mobiliser encore et
toujours les mêmes éléments de langage
se présenter comme un champion alors que
derrière il ne fait pas ce qu'il est en
train de dire et donc c'est très
problématique parce qu'en plus il ya
cette perte de confiance vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique et cette perte de
confiance elle fait que l'opinion
publique ne va peut-être pas comprendre
certaines mesures qui sont absolument
nécessaires pour maintenir des
conditions de vie sur terre et il va
s'opposer à ces mesures là et donc
toutes les questions de transition
énergétique par exemple en france
deviennent excessivement compliqué le
prix du carburant augmente etc et on ne
veut pas avoir des mesures qu'ils soient
des mesures antisociales on veut
vraiment que l'ensemble de la société et
bien prennent à bras le corps cette
crise et qu'on fasse front
collectivement et si emmanuel macron
continue de mentir ou de développer des
éléments de langage complètement vide et
de les vider de toute substance on n'y
arrivera pas vous le disiez à l'instant
il ya la flambée des prix du pétrole du
gaz depuis le mois d'août cette flambée
des prix à ce qu'elles ne risquent pas
de rendre les et que les économies
émergentes plus résistantes
finalement pour abandonner une charbon
oui évidemment c'est un risque après les
économies émergentes ont pas la même
dette climatique que les pays riches en
l'occurrence la france a une dette
climatique vraiment énorme et doit faire
sa part bien plus que les économies
émergentes
d'ailleurs la france s'était engagée à
donner 100 milliards d'euros par an pour
justement aider les pays émergents as
à la transition écologique et à
respecter leurs engagements dans le
cadre du climat elle n'en donne que 20
milliards par an en général donc on est
sur quelque chose qui ne l'est pas
peacher voilà on n'est pas dans les
clous et
donc c'était aussi une grande hypocrisie
de la part d' emmanuel macron est fière
de dire oui mais on va exiger davantage
de transparence sur comment utiliser ces
fous et c'est alors que lui même ne vois
là ne respecte pas ses engagements
encore une fois je pense que c'est
vraiment le message il y à un gap
monumental entre ce que nous dit
président de la république française et
ce qu'il fait en interne que ce soit
voilà le soutien à total que ce soit les
signature de traités de libre échange
qui encourage les flux commerciaux que
ce soit le soutient amazon le soutien
aux extensions d'aéroports en france et
là le saccage de la loi climat également
tout ça est absolument inadmissible tout
ça est absolument impossible est
intenable dans un cadre dans un monde
contraint dans un monde qui se contraint
de plus en plus est dans un cadre un
contexte de crise climatique qui est
déjà en cours en fait merci beaucoup
charlène fleury d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes porte parole dan v
comme 21